[Music]
in my bad news all damn a bad would you
do this time would you dude you up I
can't say it it's pretty gross
okay submitted by hey sisters hey but
the soul sista
hello the management team for the k-pop
group BTS has issued an apology for some
problematic outfits I did hear about
this what was it like imma sorry I
didn't mean it was a problematic one was
these like green or slipping out of the
hole or well yeah they dress up as
slaves like 100 what do they do for the
nipple my god like an Indian like Indian
are they all dudes yeah that's okay for
nipples to fall out if you do that and
in their ball sack slipped out of their
packs that was a girl group damn one two
three four all like their brothers
there's seven of them great surgeons why
did they all look like like quadruplet
like whatever it is or whatever
well there are seven tuplets how do they
even get enough time on the track for
each no it's so weird like like Korean
people know this to creep people don't
understand why this group blew up
specifically because there's nothing
special about them you know what I mean
I look like you'll be other hold on
rewind the actual music is fire
no no yes no but their music isn't any
more unique than like you a.m. 2 p.m.
all this stuff what's the difference I
went through a kpop phase and I'll let
you know BTS is the only thing that made
me come back I don't know what it is but
it's fire is bumping and I'm here for it
but that's why I'm saying but like if
you look at all the other kpop we were
afraid like the boy members i2p it's 2
p.m. to there it's not much different
you know what I mean and so like it's
such a weird anomaly or how they blew up
like I don't I don't I want to know what
the origin of how it happened because
they weren't doing anything new you mean
like blow up to the outside career world
just in general like in the kpop scene
because there's other bands that were
killing it too that did just as good
music one person like just like one
person like put it on I know that my
friend the the guy from Epic Meal Time
Harley he loves BTS my friend he's the
best but yeah he post about BTS all of
the [ __ ] time so I'm just wondering
if maybe there was some person with like
a man we put them on the map no probably
not Harley but I mean like you know like
somebody that's a good point
I guess yeah a lot of their YouTube
videos have like 300 million views like
I'm gonna start training to them then
maybe I like them I think people felt
that way about side too they're like why
this guy out of all the other talented
k-pop but he's goofy though there's like
there's a yeah that's funny there's a
theme I don't know what BTS is thing is
huh yeah so one of the member I never
even heard their stuff really or I
probably did by just don't notice and
dance to one of their songs right BTS
yeah are they nobody nobody but you know
those are like Wonder Girls Generation
connected from this [ __ ] I don't know
yes one of the members how about 24
hours yeah
yeah so one of the members with they
wore this shirt oh called it says
patriotism our history which is a brand
liberation Korea and then it has a
depiction of the atomic bombings in
Nagasaki
and yeah you weren't in Japan didn't he
it was like for a meeting or a show or
something there um so they're saying
that they will be worried during a photo
shoot I don't know where this photo
shoot took place that just reminds me of
Asians buying like clothes that just
have English on and they don't know what
it means you gotta check this out it's
like Engrish calm or like there's like a
bunch of places where there's so many
memes of like people walking around and
there's shirts that's like I like to
[ __ ] and it's a jicama or they'll have
like they'll have like a t-shirt wear
something federate flag on the back
right it's like the South should have
one oh my god cuz if you wear that you
know like in another place like somebody
probably like all that designs fire and
then it's like when you take all the
meaning out of it like it's just a
design you know Asian I saw a baby with
like a onesie and said fat dick a
Japanese television show cancelled a
live BTS performance how do they zoom in
all the way on his shirt if they saw
maybe cuz they liked the shirt they
liked manases fire there's not a big
graphic like what does it say and then
they look at it now so this is like a
tribute to South Korea's liberation from
Japan um but then it also kind of like a
death of job but a Japanese [ __ ] - that
is two hundred thousand deaths so um so
then they got a lot of flack for that
and then also this other photo popped up
we're Oh No the ring the Nazi symbol I'm
sure they don't know what their own oh
it's like side by side oh okay I was
like if they wore that over there they
were and they're having a photo shoot at
the Holocaust being well I don't know I
feel the same day is just that they just
put it side by side whoever created by
the way the the whole Nazi like you know
stigma and all that stuff and that that
symbol does not have the same weight in
Asia the way that it does in America
so it's a very Eurocentric way of
looking at the the the the stigma behind
the holes it also looks like the
Buddhists sign to it is the Buddhist
sign is the Hitler stole it flipped it
around and did his own [ __ ] thing to
it cuz he's like a cultist and like
esoteric kinda kind of guy and he loves
like symbolism right because he thought
that these symbols will give his his
team a lot of power and he he's into
branding yeah it's it's it's basically
what he did so you took that symbol
train of director yeah yeah they should
have [ __ ] the Buddhist service
[ __ ] suit his ass but for copyright
and [ __ ] that's our logo [ __ ]
yeah swastika in Buddhist temples all
over Asia on their chest yeah there's a
huge one in in Japan it's like on the
[ __ ] pillar it's a it's a big
swastika it's like in the other way
though too
I think I don't know if it's which way
is the right way or the other way but
it's clearly a swastika it's that it's
there and the middle finger means I love
you in Taiwan
[Applause]
[Music]
I told them it means peace among worlds
if you go to Taiwan just like this and
everyone so much they let you walk like
through the air party to do that it's so
crazy you see boys in Taipei no David I
got this sir please don't do that across
them we're gonna get my bows from JK
news arrested in Taiwan need to carry me
away it'll be like no I'm from JK news
it's fine it's fine
I'm taking all y'all [ __ ] with
me dude man kpop has like [ __ ]
permeated everywhere dude it is a great
time to be a little Korean boy it's been
dude for the past five years like y'all
been dominating so recent though you
know what I mean
cuz like it's just such an odd thing for
me to see for watching other cultures
try to imitate our culture when we're
imitating American pop that's truth you
know I mean like we're we're still
imitating like the wet western pop but
we added our own Korean stank to it what
and then it's being re redistributed
back out to you yeah what's blowing my
mind is all the women that's like flying
all over Europe and us to go to creative
find a Korean boyfriend
it's just crazy because like you know
all throughout life growing up everybody
wanted to be either white or black yeah
what yeah we all wanted to be white no
delay or like in probably the urban
cities cuz yeah you only had two choices
really cuz there was only two kinds of
cool was like you know you do you do
white culture stuff where you do black
cultures it depends where you are well I
mean like think about all the music that
you listen to like like Hispanic kind of
musicians or Asians or anything like in
the u.s. in the u.s. yeah yeah when we
were in high school yeah yeah we are in
high school it was my very [ __ ]
limited yeah but you want right
like a more of a wiping yeah all the
subcultures were pretty much dominated
by that except for the import scene the
import seemed erase the car important
all that Street agent that's when we
started coming in but then even the Fast
and Furious franchise took that over and
took it away from the Asians and made it
more mainstream
that's our invention that's our thing
you know what I mean like but it's it's
totally different now look I like this
that's cool everybody y'all can be black
now from the asian come on give us a
spotlight it's very different now ya
know but if you think about it right
like imagine okay I don't know how you
how much younger you are from me but
like in high school it was either like
hardcore like hip-hop heads or like rock
stuff either black culture or white
culture that's it where I was the I
think the demographic is like 6% black
so like yeah so all of us were white on
paper too survived yeah but there's also
a lot of when you watch like all those
you know TV shows like Jenny Jones or
whatever right there were so many white
kids that thought they were black it was
always like a white girl with cornrows
saying don't judge me yeah it's like go
you live and you see like their home and
where they live they live in an
all-white neighborhood yeah and they
it's like where do you get your accent
where did you get that like she listens
to way too much [ __ ] rap and she wants
to be black you never seen that part did
that [ __ ] I've seen a handful of them I
feel like I feel like some people would
consider Danielle Britt goalie in that
category yeah but that was I feel like
that was way bigger back then like I
would see it all over them you know did
he put out a tweak not too long ago
where he was there was a bunch of kids
they were like rapping or whatever right
and they got cash outs but it's like
seven little like eight and ten twelve
year old white boys you know just
[ __ ] with the cash out wrapping his
[ __ ] doing whatever and I did he put out
a tweet where he was like I guess like
he doesn't like when
I guess like when white culture takes a
part of black culture that's been
developing you know and it kind of takes
their identity when they that ownership
of that culture interesting but there
was another counterpart to that saying
like okay but you as an entertainer as a
rapper you're selling it to everybody
else as a commodity and a product and
now you're saying don't follow it when
you just make billions off of it yeah so
how does that work out like are you
trying to keep it exclusive or are you
trying to make it inclusive how's ocean
I don't know which you know I was like
kind of like oh [ __ ] I don't know what
to think about that you know India so
it's something that's very like
culturally identifying which is like
hip-hop to like black culture but their
main market that they're selling to our
bunch these white kids and then like
that's how NWA got so damn big yeah
because it was like the biggest buyer of
their music was middle America white
kids yeah hmm personally it doesn't it
doesn't faze me because where I grew up
nobody wanted to be black so just seeing
somebody want to be black I'm like take
it take it because I never I never got
to see that I didn't like yeah [ __ ] I
this is how crazy was in junior high I
had a classmate and and she's she's
Filipino and then she she grew up in the
hood right so so she's you know all of
her friends were basically black but she
openly said if I find out that one of my
family members married a black person
I'd be so happy and I was like you don't
you're not proud of being Filipino it
she goes I am but we're not that cool
like I want I want to be black like
openly yeah openly I was like damn
nothing I feel like that's how most of
the Asian homies feel like now I see
like a white person eat kimchi I'm like
yeah you eat that rotten [ __ ] dude yeah
that smelly ass fishy [ __ ] bro
[Music]